need motivation watch a top ten with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you as well you've got Michael Jordan
level talent at something so get ready
to play it smart don't waste money and
do things your way with Mark Cuban and
my take on his top ten was a success vol
7 to give you the confidence motivation
and belief that you need enjoy
ok let's kick it off with rule number
one play it smart when instead of just
holding on to all of the stock that you
got from Yahoo you did what we call a
collar you collar hedge yeah so you
hedged it so tell everybody what went
through your mind pick us that was a big
bet with huge dollars right and it was a
pretty it was actually pretty simple so
you know hedging stock if you know Yahoo
paid us in Yahoo stock and you know I
had I was smart enough to recognize I
guess that what goes up could go down
but it wasn't that biggest step because
I was worth more than a billion dollars
how much did I need right so I was
telling everybody just find me a way to
hedge it so in the event look if the
stock price goes up and I leave
something on the table so be it right
but no I like that be next to my name
and I wanted to keep it and so I sold
calls bought puts and effectively hedged
it so that by the time so there was a
period of time from when I'd done that
and the internet stock market kept on
going up and and I told people I'd
hedged it and Goldman Sachs the company
had told people what I'd done and I
remember going on CNBC the business
Channel and then the guy going don't you
feel stupid that Yahoo stock is kept on
going up and you had this hedge and I'm
like yeah I feel so stupid riding around
my g5 that I bought online
and and it was just like have to sound
like crazy greedy greedy capitalist but
yeah and it was like I just don't want
to screw it up and so I hedged it and
then the internet bubble burst and I was
fully protected and actually even made a
little bit more money and you know
middle um you know the motto that the
what I learned was he just don't need to
be greedy you know I was very very
blessed I was very fortunate you look I
didn't plan the internet stock market to
go up and I'd have planted to go down so
I was lucky in terms of scale and I
didn't want to screw it up and so I
hedged rule number two pay attention to
history when you have a good idea right
you ask your friends you ask for
feedback around you said oh I'm all
excited it's a great idea right my
friends liked it I can't fight what do
you do next
you go to Google right and you put it in
there and you say it's this this this
this this you find 50 different keyword
searches and you say there's nothing
there right Wow there must be it must be
a great idea no one else is doing it
wrong the reason there's nothing there
is the 15 people did it before you are
out of business their web servers are
down and they're not indexed anymore and
there's no sense of history and a lot of
the things that are happening you know
because and particularly with mobile
apps because there's no real web there
there's like a one-page website up that
directs you to the mobile app there's
nothing indexing the app and so a lot of
50 different people are doing the same
app and you know and because you can't
get a URL it's you know the xxxx app
right and it's xxx app and it's hard to
find the comparables and it's hard to
learn from the history of it and so it's
whether it's Google whether it's
Facebook the real challenge right now on
starting a company is you can't learn
from history because all the history is
gone and that's all least have that may
be it yeah holds us back and maybe you
know it's the worst thing that could
happen is you know being you know
ignorant of what happened Mike you know
is probably better in a lot of cases and
but sometimes it's not and so I think
that's one of the biggest challenges
that entrepreneurs face today that
there's no history to really go back to
look at rule number three put in sweat
equity raising money
it always seems to be like the big thing
to entrepreneurs coming in well if I can
only raise this money raising money
isn't an accomplishment it's an
obligation the best equity is sweat
equity you know what you can do and what
you seriously if you're putting in there
if you're putting in the sweat and
you're putting in the time and you're
not out there raising money and you're
grinding it out and you're hustling then
you deserve to give yourselves a hand
because that's what it's all about
because if you don't do that it's not
gonna work rule number four don't waste
money I gave it a good go right from oh
one two oh eight we turn it back up but
it was they they did slip on a big
banana peel purple and yellow banana
peel for Yahoo for you that know their
colors another thing way do you it's so
we we sell to them right and our offices
in Dallas and the way we ran our
business it was just like lean and mean
right you invest in your product you
invest in your customers you invest in
your people and you know we had open
offices you don't need fancy stuff they
immediately came down and just we did
all the furniture and purple and gold
I'm like it's cool that's my high
school's colors you know but why are we
spending this money got a whole new
office a whole new building you know I'm
just like why are we spending this money
one of the things in my rules right when
I look at companies to invest in if
someone walks in was swag here's my
coffee mug with my logo
here's your t-shirt with my logo I don't
see anybody wearing a t-shirt with a
startups logo do you know would you wear
some other startups logo polo shirt hell
no hell no right it's just a waste of
money you know put your money where
you're able to differentiate yourself
and add value that set separate yourself
so you can get ahead don't waste it
also if you want to have more confidence
checking my 254 series they're free the
links to join are in the description
below I've always been passionate some
people thought you know it's a it's more
OCD than anything else
I always did everything back-ass half
words you know I like to challenge
myself those back-to-back experiences
confirmed what I already knew that I was
yes employee and then I better start my
rule number five put customers first
there people often ask me what it takes
to start a business what is the key
ingredient how did I how do I start the
business and how do we grow to about 20
million dollar 20 million dollars in
sales so quickly you know they all come
up with some new whiz-bang idea they're
gonna invent the the better mousetrap
they're gonna come up with new software
new hardware and whatnot it seems like
they've spent their millions before they
thought through their idea but when we
talk about new companies and and growth
and success there really is only one
common ingredient across any type of
business whether it's oil or computers
or software anything and that key
ingredient is customers without
customers when you're starting a
business running a business expanding a
business you don't have a business there
is no business customers are the key
ingredient to get those profits you
gotta have the customers and you gotta
have happy customers that's the bottom
line
you know micro solutions we've been
we've been going and growing and it's
impossible not to have growing pains
it's impossible not to make mistakes we
screw up all the time and you know it
doesn't bother me as president if I have
it if I have an employee who just didn't
do something right just made a mistake
it's good because if you're not making
mistakes you're not trying hard enough
you know these things I'm saying they're
not unique they're not things that I
just thought up in some some miracle
growth you know things when I talk to
people in our company when I talk to
people about our company I never had a
unique thought I can't remember I don't
know that I ever did I can't remember if
I ever will or don't expect ever to
there's no magic formulas to customer
service there's no magic formulas to
doing things right these are these
things that you hear me say with things
that I've read elsewhere and and just
regurgitate back but how many people do
them you know we all know the Golden
Rule do unto others as you would have
them do unto you and that's nice
you know but do you do it but even more
importantly than you go and roll what
about the lovers
do you want the others as you would love
to have them do unto you
that's what we try to stress a micro
solution that's what we try to use to
differentiate ourselves not just to get
by because everybody's gonna be nice
yeah when you invite someone into your
house that is an acquaintance that you
like okay you're gonna offer me coffee
you're gonna offer them a doughnut and
that's really what you expect you know
if you went to their house because
you're just acquaintances
but when you leave the house it was nice
if you go that's fine if you don't feel
that fine that's the way customers look
at businesses if I go back fine I don't
go back fine you know they say that 80%
of people who have a problem tell at
least 10 people only a 10% of the people
who had a good experience tell anybody
and it's the same way when you go to
visit an acquaintance and when people
come to try to do business with micro
solutions I hope I pray and I try to
convey that each and every one of our
people that we give them a reason to
want to come back we give them the
reason to do a good morning rap to say
okay let's do business with micro
solutions you've got to really
concentrate to do unto others as you
would love to have them do unto you
rule number six do things your way I
dropped out of high school so I wanted
to take business and the high school I
went to didn't offer any business
classes unless I was a senior in high
school and I'm like come on I mean I'm
trying to be ambitious and they're like
no and so um I took some classes at
night at the University of Pittsburgh
and then just since I was enrolled at
Pitt I just stopped going to class in
high school and kept on going to class
at Pitt and they allowed me to transfer
back my credits to graduate from high
school so I officially was a high school
dropout until I rectified that rule
number seven be brutally honest with
yourself even after you had done your
thing there was still an eight-course to
make sure that yahoo itself was on track
you know what that was about
yeah they were screwing everything up
you know I mean look they had they had
an opportunity to dominate streaming
media they also owned at the same time
the patent to cost-per-click Yeah right
now
Google's entire business to this day is
built around
pay-per-click rather not concrete click
yeah so they had the entire patent for
pay-per-click had they just said sorry
Google you can't use it there would be
no Google instead they said you have one
hundred thirty three million dollars and
give us some stock they were just too
nice right which blinded them in a lot
of respects and I remember walking in
with a thirty two million dollar sale
saying okay we're gonna do streaming
we're gonna sell all this company's
content you know it's worth thirty two
million dollars for us and it's going to
pre up these other potential competitors
and I forget if it's Jerry or Tim or
whoever said no we don't work that way
we don't pre up competition we just
leave it open okay it's time for me to
go buy a basketball team that's they
just they just didn't see these things
and I mean it's a lesson in your
businesses there's going to be
everybody's always trying to kick your
ass and you have to figure out how to
kick your out your own ass first
seriously because if you're not brutally
honest with yourself in your own
business about what your frailties are
someone else is going to find them Yahoo
didn't get that Yahoo just thought you
know what we're just going to continue
moving forward and then we'll just
compete with everybody else and you know
there's we have no other problems didn't
quite work out for them did it rule
number eight no you're why when I talk
to entrepreneurs you have to make a
decision what's important to you time to
go out and do whatever be whoever you
are help you ever you want to help raise
your family whatever it is or do you
want to create a world-class company
what is your goal and you have to
understand your goals and there should
always be a price you know if there's a
if it is about selling at some point
what's the price I just have
conversations with to my companies today
like you always have to have a price in
mind and then you put that price out
there cuz someone might say yes so
always be open to it but just always
know why you're there right what what is
it that causes you to work 24 hours a
day what is it that causes you to dream
about this company what is it that gets
you so fired up you can't think about
anything else
what is it just that you just say this
is me right I am that you know what is
that that what is it that drives you
and if you understand that then deciding
to sell or not to sell is easy rule
number nine solve problems I went on you
know I went to Indiana and in Dallas in
the mid-90s you know when we had a good
basketball team we literally would when
we wanted to listen to our big games
like Indiana Purdue go Hoosiers we would
call somebody in Bloomington who would
put a radio next to a speaker phone and
dial us and we sit on the other side
listening over a speaker from drinking
our beer and whooping it up or doing
whatever and the internet was just
starting to happen and now I'm the tech
geek and I'm like into all of it and
we're like there's got to be a better
way to do this and so one of my buddies
from Indiana Todd Wagner was like look
we've been thinking about this and I'm
like no I'll figure it out I'm a
networking guy now and so we looked for
ways to stream Indiana basketball we'd
called it net casting back then over the
brand-new Internet and so I went out and
bought a Packard Bell 90 megahertz
computer and an ISDN line and downloaded
all this software and I said you know
what I'm gonna figure it out and lo and
behold by oh golly
early 1995 we had figured out a way to
we would we took these eight-hour VCRs
and connected it to a local radio
station record them we'd bring them back
go through this process called encoding
and put it up on this website we called
audio net and then I'd go to any online
forum AOL prodigy CompuServe uu net
whatever it was or you use use use nap
and I like if you're interested in
Dallas sports at all because we hadn't
gotten to Indiana yet if you're
interested in Dallas sports go to this
website audio net and back man you had a
dial-up modem you had to download this
software called tcp/ip and you had to
have software from your internet
provider which meant that so few people
knew how to use it we had no idea if it
would work or not but all of a sudden
Audio net went from 10 people a day to a
hundred people to a thousand people a
day and as we added radio stations there
getting calls from all over the world
from people who are listening to their
shows on demand
not even line and then we worked with
the company that put together live soft
for cover called zing and we made it
live and then everything changed and
that's really when streaming was born
and we just grew that and then in 1998
we got into video changed the name to
broadcast comm went public and it was
the biggest IPO in the history of the
stock market at the time and then we
sorted - to Yahoo I'm rule number ten
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is focus on the AI Vladimir Putin
says the winner in AI controls the world
China put together a future plan I'm
saying you know whoever dominates in AI
and they're subsidizing you know $0.10
Alibaba etc yeah right that's right
there that's they know it's a race it is
a race we cut our office of technology
and science to one person who was an
assistant to Peter Thiel that's where we
stand so when we talk about
infrastructure jobs you know robots are
built in Germany and they're getting by
by Chinese companies in some respects
and I think some Japanese companies
might as well we don't build robots here
very well right I just invested in my
first robotics company hire bollocks
that puts robots into companies it
they're in Kansas City I think it is now
but they they lease and rent and sell
robots into all these different types of
circumstances to replace people huh
right but I had to learn I'm not saying
it's a good thing or bad thing it's
gonna happen with or without me but I
wanted to learn what was going on those
building up a robotics industry here
investing in our AI industry here that's
the new infrastructure yeah because if
we don't do it in China or Russia or
Windows Wars we're Sol right we're out
of luck right and so when we talk about
the price of assets going up when if
you're hiring you know if you're talking
about intellectual assets if you're
hiding like we were just saying the
price is skyrocketing people you know
Montreal has become the center of the
universe for computer vision it's not
us-based schools that are dominating any
longer in those areas we've got a lot of
smart kids in MIT all different schools
right and kids are starting to realize
discipline
for them to go and I'm out there telling
people the first trillionaire is going
to come from somebody who comes up with
something really unique in nai now I've
got a special bonus tip for mark on how
to believe more in yourself that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one what is your why
number two what big problem are you
solving and number three where do you
need to get more brutally honest with
yourself the shark tank thing again I'll
say it I can't say it enough times it's
the fact that I truly truly am part of
the solution to letting people know that
anybody with a little bit of work a
little bit of help a little bit of
vision can do anything
takes luck no it's not gonna happen to
everybody right not everybody has the
resources but if they watch Shark Tank
and there's just one thing that they
learn or just as inspires them to say
okay if this person from Iowa can go on
Shark Tank and I like that idea or they
can get an investment or even if they
don't get investment they can create a
business that's successful whether
they're 15 years old whether they're 80
years old whatever it is if they can do
it I can do it and if I can be part of
that how cool is that
if you want more Mark Cuban and check
that the top-50 rules video I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there the
challenge is you know are you willing to
do the work you don't have to look the
part I mean I certainly never have right